however I've ever told you about the Tai
Chi Hitler stuff no let me let me see if
I can find this aisle please oh my G
Hitler stuff tell me tell me about Tai
Chi Hitler I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
play maybe I should play I mean is it an
anime to something no let's uh let's
let's pull this up Hulk vs. Hitler
finger family nursery oh this thing you
were talking about the other day whoa my
ears hurt let's see let's see sorry if
that affect it alright there you go
for those that are watching we got Adolf
Hitler and what looks like some kind of
Hulk monster it looks like a lizard Hulk
and and now and so what it is I'm not
gonna play the audio it's really creepy
look at this what is that that is not
that's like sasquatch Hulk oh wait look
here's a green bikini lady and Catwoman
doing the same thing and then a finger
comes up with the green lady's face what
is going what are we watching
we are watching I feel like we just
jumped into the SJW hole right I don't
know if that has anything to do with it
it does it feels like we're in a hole
sometimes oh this is a nursery rhyme for
children this way you're talking about
the other day yeah yeah yeah yeah for
those of you that are listening I'm
gonna explain this to you wow we're
looking at this freaky Hulk vs. Hitler
3d animation nursery rhymes & this is
the easiest way I can explain to people
social justice politics yeah so let me
explain to you why this video exists
please try to explain it to me mothers I
don't get it we're giving babies iPads
right I'm gonna put the iPad infront of
the baby and they would turn on finger
family nursery rhyme okay the original
videos are just like Dora the Explorer
dancing around and it sings its nursery
rhyme which I'm not gonna sing because
people get mad at me cuz I get stuck in
their head where it like basically names
all the fingers okay YouTube's autoplay
algorithm doesn't differentiate between
substance it only interacts with like
are you watching for a long time okay
and are the keywords relevant right the
algorithm algorithm at the time is
several years ago like just it didn't
work very well and so what ends up
happening is when a baby is laying in a
crib and the iPad is just playing Auto
play for hours first it'll play a real
nursery rhyme video then it'll play
another real nursery rhyme video okay
but then the quality will start to
degrade this video was developed by
people in India who used basically
keyword scrapers right to figure out
what was getting the most plays on
YouTube and make stuff that would also
and it's basically yeah and so what
happens is after a you know a few runs
the autoplay algorithm on YouTube would
play complete garbled nonsense right now
here's it's funny when you look at that
as a sentient human adult who is like
learn it even a little bit you're like
this is insane yes but what would happen
if someone took an amalgamation of
general politics and mashed it all
together and then presented it for you
it would look real to a baby they can't
tell the difference they see this the
babies like huh that's just yep that's
the only thing I know yeah
so here's what happens with social
justice politics Facebook started the
early on in Facebook's days a bunch of
blogs started popping up like Huffington
Post BuzzFeed and they found that by
exploiting faith Facebook's algorithm
they could get a ton of shares on their
articles and make a lot of money okay
it was completely dependent upon
Facebook people on Facebook clicking
share something truly fascinating ends
up happening on a website like having a
post will write about a police-brutality
article okay you know like some police
brutality thing happens 100,000 shares
they get 10 million views in their life
we just made 40 grand off of that one
article it took you ten minutes to write
yeah write more yeah yeah but then
something even stranger heavens BuzzFeed
writes about sexism and that also gets
10 million right
so the algorithm says sexism show this
more because people share it racism
show this more because people share it
and then a light bulb appeared over
Jonah these racist
boom boo yeah making the money and
that's how you get intersectional
feminism so so now on Facebook all of a
sudden they started jamming as many
things as possible into their articles
and so intersectionality was the
keyman it was the obvious outcome of
Facebook's algorithm
algorithmic manipulation an article
about sexism gets you x views yeah an
article about racism gets you y views an
article about sexism and racing gets you
x + y views all i can think of is that
that woman talking about Ivanka and how
that article just had every his every
different point she could even exact we
were like how did it even go there but
nope she was just putting it all in
there to hit the hit all the checkboxes
and it might not even be on purpose it
might be a natural tendency so here's
what happens buzz I mentioned when I say
Jonah Peretti in BuzzFeed those are
hypotheticals I'm using them as examples
because this is what they're accused of
doing by like jeff jarvis is a professor
and he did some twitter thread about how
BuzzFeed's whole business model was
basically using Facebook's algorithm
okay when Facebook changed this they all
panicked and lost a ton of money and
laid a ton of people off so but now we
now we end up seeing this tendency
occurs right the first thing that
happened was this crib learn ooze pops
up right Oh a legitimate curricular news
pops up on Facebook it's not a thing but
it could be umbilical so let's say the
years 2007 and someone creates the crib
look the the crib LinkedIn post Oh an
interesting twist yes the crib LinkedIn
post is great news straight news
yo only the real news there's only the
rig mminton and so it was articles that
were like today in Syria
17 fighters approached the US border and
you know surrendered really really
boring dry stuff okay at the same time
The Huffington Post pops up
they both publish articles kriging 10
News Brooklyn Post is straightforward
fair and objective that's right in post
is shock content outrage
intersectionality guess which one gets
more shares not Crick LinkedIn post I'm
sorry no no it was that the
straightforward news pillage didn't want
it we had to go under so now what
happens is the real news goes out of
business no venture capitalists start
seeing have it impose all these
companies and so they're like let's dump
some money into this you know it's
making money boom all of a sudden ease
companies were worth hundreds of
millions of dollars they're getting
crazy investment I mean Vox got like you
know 200 million vais got like five
hundred million just just
it all in light it up and this propped
up these companies now they were funded
something else funny happens so you get
a company like vise what do they do they
hire people like me they hire a bunch of
cool people who know how to do news and
do real legit on-the-ground reporting
they also hire some rage bait sjw types
guess which content gets more money yeah
so guess who eventually falls off the
budget locator to you well not me I quit
right I left the I they probably have
kept me there forever yeah if I was
still there yeah pushed you further and
further away though because you you
didn't fall in line with what they were
doing though you know no advice I don't
see I don't know with Vice I was playing
I was doing everything they wanted okay
yeah I mean vice was was developing
things around what I was doing like yeah
it's complicated but Shane's course it
is well yeah of course it's not so
simple especially building vice news but
Shane said at the knight Foundation
awards someone asked him do you ever
think you do vice would be doing
on-the-ground reporting and he was like
no I wasn't until you know Tim Poole
came and I think you're sitting right
over there and I was like oh wow I
already quit at that point I was like I
appreciate it man so they didn't want to
do it was difficult they were resisting
I was like I want to do field reporting
and they're like we don't do that we do
documentary stuff and I'm like I want to
do it yeah and then Rocco who's working
on scanner now was actually a big
advocate like you got a look at what
this dude's doing he's crazy so they
started building stuff around it but I
could see where things were going
because it was slowly turning into a
corporate machine okay and I knew where
that would have turn it would they'll
become but there's there's another
there's another big aspect to this right
so I ended up joining fusion and at
first these companies weren't infected
the infection spreads to them right vice
is actually all right
no no vice was was making money off
being like the opposite of a lot of
these social justice companies for one
reason or another more like having to do
with the aki's the the sexual harassment
accusations against higher-ups advice
they started adopting this stuff and I
think has to do a lot with the investors
who are looking like these other
companies and they're like this what we
have to do to avoid these scandals
mm-hmm but the infection hit the people
who are more likely to write articles to
get traffic for social justice rage bait
writers you know so they were more
likely to keep their
because there they got the views they
made the money and the companies became
social justice rage Beija rage bait
outlets and that was the spread of the
infection and it's funny because a lot
of people would say things like you know
Tim Poole doesn't get it you know this
was a years like 2014 stuff 2015 and
when they were talking about gamergate
and like video games being infected with
social justice stuff yeah and I was like
the video game stuff it's actually
really really obvious how that all
started let's say you write for a video
game outlet okay what do you write about
today little game come out of some
destiny we need personally yeah yeah I
mean I would be talking about the game
the mechanics of the game okay
probably I'm right now I would probably
talk about revenant and new stuff that's
coming out no it's been out for a little
bit but it's not really well known and
it's an incredibly fun game what are you
write about tomorrow probably a
different game I would just go through
all the games I play it's a news outlet
we're not just doing you know you're not
just doing reviews or dudes the news
what's the news man did something happen
in gaming that's it's actually the
probably talk about the the dear person
but that's that's a one-off you know
then what I would do any of the games
I would I would much as I could the
answer is you can't it's impossible yeah
what is news in games it's like so a
games coming out you make you know games
getting reviewed yeah that's what I
would and so some of these journalistic
gaming sites would do a big like
encyclopedia basically like a game guide
okay so some of these gaming outlets
you'd go there and you'd see like a ton
of articles about how to do certain
things but when you're when your job is
to write five articles a day and it's
about gaming
what are you write about man what do you
do well we wrote for articles those
every game coming out this month yeah
now I got to write five articles every
day for the rest of the month social
justice fake controversy they make it up
like that woman we mentioned about the
the Ivanka Trump article right for those
that aren't familiar it was this article
that said okay Ivanka Trump responded to
Elon Musk oh right Elon Musk said take
the red pill Ivanka said taken and she
writes 400 words about in cells and
misogyny and the what this really means
about Ivanka and I'm like bro she said a
five letter word
but she stuffed everything in there
everything yep and so she might not even
do that on purpose that could just be
that like I ran out of steam and I no
need to write another one no she is the
natural crazy person who writes crazy
nonsense whose articles work hmm she
might not be consciously being like hmm
how do i craft a lie and so it happens a
lot of these companies people think that
journalists are like told to do this and
they do nah man they're the ones who
survived the industry is collapsing you
know at the Atlantic just laid off 20%
of its staff yeah who do you think
stayed do you think the let me tell you
something man go to an investor it's a
good point go to an investor all right
and tell them this I want to start a
news company and we're gonna do a really
big news investigation okay
investor is gonna ask you how much that
cost first year full investigation we're
gonna need at least two other people on
staff we're getting a travel budget
we're need equipment
oh man to get off the ground for a good
investigative reporter we're talking
like 100k like I talking like a good one
I got award-winning like we're gonna
lose gonna be big right yeah okay let's
roll that down it's gonna be a new
company we got some young upstarts we're
gonna pay him 50 because they live in
New York and this is their demand
because other companies pay comparably
so we've got two people at 50 we're
gonna buy a bunch of cameras we're gonna
put probably you know 30 or 40 in
production so I'm gonna need like 100
200
just in staffing then I'm gonna need
like 50 in office space and then I'm
gonna need probably like a hundred in
travel and everything else so let's just
let's just call through Newark a
investors gonna say all right sounds
good what's our projection after one
three or five years and you're gonna say
nothing nothing and nothing okay well
hold on man you're asking me for
$300,000 what do you mean nothing all
right
nothing we might not even get the story
bro we might spend a year investigating
and nothing comes out of it and that
budget were asking for it's for one year
you want to talk a three-year budget
will mean a million dollars not to
mention inflation costs salaries and
everything so you mean to tell me I'm
the investor you mean tell me that you
want a million dollars for three
operations with no guarantees of
anything produced daddy I'm not paying
for that yeah that's not
and another guy walks up and says buddy
buddy I'll tell you what you give me
five grand right now I'll hire a
freelancer four hundred bucks to write
me some nonsense about some racist video
gamer I'll make it $2,000 return like
that overnight we're gonna gain the
algorithm
five grand that's it yup five grand
that's it what do I get out of that I
think I'd turn into 50 how long a couple
weeks deal there you go now people are
being inundated with us across the board
you look at CNN they're struggling
they're burning to the ground so what do
they do
let's play the game baby yeah let's play
the game you think that infection that
you're talking about the SJW like click
baby stuff that's kind of the reason why
all these Cairns are going nuts because
they're well look at what what's being
spread around on the Internet this must
be the way life is this is turning into
it
the toxic masculinity well look these
are the articles that are being shared
this must be the way things are kind of
yes the infections growing in people's
my it's not making them Karan's it's
activating the Karen gene there it is
yeah it's like it's like in the X gene
so what happens is if they see nothing
but content where it tells them people
not wearing masks bad what do they do
you ever see ever see invasion of the
body snatchers
no we've referenced it and so there's a
people yelled at me to watch it because
let me let me pull up this tweet that I
posted I got to do something navigating
but Cassandra Fairbanks who is funny she
posted this clip from these these
Karen's who are screeching at somebody
for not wearing a mask oh yeah I've seen
it
and so I posted I posted a video and I
want to play the sound
oh no I probably can't play the sound I
think we might be able to anyway I'll
just show you the image oh this is from
the movie yeah so here watch this is
Donald Sutherland walks up she's and he
goes like this screaming flagged if I
play it he's like oh because he's been
body-snatched body-snatched he's like
that's the joke right yeah so that's
what happens the Karen gene people
people want to fit in right yeah and so
they don't to be ostracized if the only
sane thing they see every day they're
being inundated
the same same narrative mm-hmm a
narrative makes no sense then they just
say like whatever that is right yeah it
makes sense to them no it doesn't make
sense and they know it hmm that's why
they don't do their use absolutely
that's why they don't do interviews man
they don't want to because they know
they're they have no ideology they have
they all they have is the tribe the
collective you know and if they defy it
they'll get cancelled and the rules
change every day so if you do an
interview and you say something about
them tomorrow the rule might be
different
so anyway here was the point who's the
part was gonna make about the the video
of the Hitler dancing right right you
can see all of the weird keywords mashed
together that makes no sense but in
order to exploit an adult you need to
take things that make sense and then
present it in a way where they're like I
know what these things are and then you
need to figure out how you can connect
them that's why the rules change so
often because it doesn't make sense at
all like what is or isn't offensive
makes literally no sense but mash all of
these different political causes into
one and you end up with like the Muslim
LGBT alliance where you have in the UK
Muslims showing up to protest the LGBT
curriculum in was it in Birmingham or
Burma yeah an elementary school was
doing LGBT curriculum Muslims protested
it and they were fighting with each
other yet intersection like actually a
better example than this too is our
slash atheism on reddit it is a
subreddit a forum with millions of
people dedicated to ragging on religion
okay but for the most part just
Christians you can try Muslims during
oppressed minority and so there was like
recently a really funny post where was
someone criticizing Islam mm-hmm and all
of the comments were walking on
eggshells nothing that was look if you
want to talk about Christianity they're
like dude these backwater yokel morons
so stupid Trump chud's and they just go
nuts right on Christians Islam they're
like you know I think it's fair to say
we can criticize and talk critically
unfortunately too much of these people I
have hidden motives and it's like are
you kidding me dude like you want a
right on religion religion bro where'd
all the Internet's ass go
it's it's it's it's about what's safe
hmm and you know it's interesting
because uh we we did an event there's a
group called mythos system Milwaukee ok
we did an event they did an event in
Milwaukee I showed the last minute and
there's like an interesting break in the
atheist community and I think that
there's a really weird thing that
happened in the early 2010's okay where
the left and the right like spun in a
weird way and then split in half so it's
like like a polar shift not really like
maybe maybe like maybe like a polar
shift but you now have like there are
people I know who made lefty anti-war
videos there now suit-wearing mcgee hat
dudes and I'm like how did that happen
yeah
how did that happen like that's a change
Walker shark away yeah for sure
but there are people who are a lot like
us who for the most part are the exact
same
talk about the exact same things but
everything else shifted around us yeah
definitely so like the best example is
these people advice being like man you
change dude like what happened and I'm
like bro remember when you wrote that
edgy article yeah I'm like I didn't even
write that there's one dude who became
an overt sjw and then people looked at
his history writing for Vice and they
were like bro you are the most racist
sexist we've ever seen yeah and he was
like oh well I mean i disavow my past
and they were like don't care you're
cancelled and like just light him up
online like just go at him like crazy
but these are the people that just
they're The Grifters and they accuse
everyone else of being a grifter it's
sad dude when like I have good friends
that I've known for years and let me
hang out we have a good time
to hear what they're saying now and I'm
like directly breaking the law their
companies are advocating for things that
are outright illegal how do you oh just
like hiring those people yeah and I'm
like how do you how do you go from being
like we need the Civil Rights Act to
prevent discrimination in the hiring
process - two years later being like I'm
gonna hi I'm gonna discriminate against
the people I'm hiring it's like so so
it's it's illegal to say I want to hire
this specific type of person for the
most part yes okay like if you came if
there was a job posting that said you
know we're looking for a janitor but man
only okay super illegal if it said
Christians only illegal if it said
Americans only illegal like even even I
think national origin is yeah yeah yeah
so so now what's happening is you've got
people putting putting up posts being
like we're only hiring women we're only
doing this there are exceptions for
modeling entertainment performance for
obvious reasons mm-hm and there are some
exceptions that can be argued in court
like that's at the point of judges are
for right like copyright infringement
and fair use literally everything is
copyright infringement that's under fair
use but it's an exemption so you can be
sued and then you'll win on a fair use
grounds okay so like when I show a news
article and I'm talking about it and
reading and commenting yeah yeah
technically that's infringement right
except it's fair use so you know it's
public yeah yeah yeah so when it comes
to these like employment violations for
like you think about who was who was
posting these jobs like you know
so-and-so need not apply in the 60s long
haired freaky people you got apply
rakish long haired freaky people I think
you're allowed to discriminate against
long haired for you know never work
again long haired today it's like what
am I supposed to say to somebody who's
become like a hardcore racist and
they're in the dogma and it's like the
courageous thing is it's all tied
together with politics yeah
so the lockdown is part of it too these
same people what makes it even worse
though it becomes part of their like
emotions you know so even having a
logical conversation with someone like
that like yes like how do you talk to
someone like that you almost can't you
can't because as soon as you go against
what they believe they get triggered and
you can't have a logical peaceful
conversation because they their emotions
just shoot through the roof and then
that starts driving you know it's there
whatever everything they're talking
about yeah you're going against their
worldview and that's you you don't do
that as soon as you do that boom
emotionally over the same thing it's
even crazy a life food you know talking
about people people well like people get
triggered whenever the word vegan comes
around it's like oh my gosh trigger
it's like whoa I don't care about what
you eat don't-don't-don't even say it's
like the other day he said you know man
vegans talking about food and was like
it wasn't even me I wasn't really
talking about you were talking about it
you know and it's like that's getting
you Jew there's a triggered that that
happens against the world view it's like
you know that happens pretty much to
everyone on different different levels
but especially in this situation you
know I mean exactly
so it's like when people bring up the
vegan stuff it's usually not as heated
as the political stuff absolutely yeah
but people always but it about well when
you get crazy vegans which there's
certainly crazy vegans out there you
know they'll they've they'll attack even
me for having like a pet you know we're
having pets too some vegans is like whoa
whoa you're using them as love slaves
it's like yeah yeah that's what that's
what humans have done for a long time
like okay anyway yes pretty funny it's
it's impossible to have a conversation
with somebody who has adopted a dogmatic
worldview yeah and what's blows my mind
is that right now the religious right
are the ones begging for the
conversation yeah that's a good point
and I think like a Ben Shapiro is a
great example like how often he's had
can't calm conversations about what he
thinks and what he believes even if he's
wrong even if people call him out even
if they make videos on YouTube or
they're like here's ben shapiro being
wrong
he doesn't scream at people and freak
out you can see that he has his debates
yeah but that's what we need right how
do we come to a point where this like
inversion happened where Jon Stewart was
making fun of everybody and it was funny
and yet George Carlin and it was like oh
man these authoritarian it's like the
libertarian shift happened maybe it's
like the pendulum of libertarianism and
I'm gonna left for a while now it's on
the right for a while and it's like a
Thor changement goes up and then it goes
down it goes back and forth or whatever
yeah now it's the right and so if you're
if you're mostly just a libertarian type
you are now more likely to have a good
conversation with Trump supporters
conservatives and if not with the left
yeah you can't further yourself if
you're just only gonna believe what you
believe you you have to you have to be
here the other side of it too you know
oh how do you know it's it's dark at
night well because it's bright during
the day and then gets dark at night I
looked out my window yeah
let me stop you right there buddy it's
the middle need to look out the window
to know when night and day is hilarious
okay here's another example of like the
it's just just the dementia that's
affecting this these group of descrip of
people mm-hmm
somebody I made up somebody commented in
reply to like Trump he's Trump apply
guys and they said something like you
know there's only been ever been one
instance of known voter fraud from male
and voting it was a Republican and so I
quoted that in saying woe or Republican
tried cheat with male and voting that's
a good reason for Democrats to oppose it
I didn't say I was for or against
mail-in voting I was poking fun at the
argument that you're accusing
Republicans of cheating and being in
favor of make voting like how does that
make sense right right and so then
someone responded with are you seriously
opposed to mail-in voting you Mogga
Trump stirs need to blah blah blah and
took some high-profile guys had this
somewhat responded with Tim lays out his
position in the evidence here and put
links on my videos his immediate
response was let me stop you right there
buddy I don't need to watch a video to
understand that these people are stupid
blah blah blah blah be like my position
was for the most part we do have
evidence of voter fraud we shouldn't be
changing the rules of an election six
months before an election that seems
nonsensical you can say the same for
about literally any I don't care if the
Republican Democrat if you want to
change the rules you want mail and
voting you got to do it beforehand
pandemics happen you can't argue but
word of emergency now yeah okay well
then where's your emergency provision
for how elections are dealt with during
an emergency
you can't just sign an executive decree
and mail out ballots and be like we've
changed the whole thing so this is a
person who says I don't need to see the
evidence I'm just going to whinge it's
happening nowadays that's the thing to
do thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you